-Guys, it's time for
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
Here we go.
-♪ Hashtags ♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
-Guys, we do this thing every
week where I send out a hashtag,
and we ask you guys
to respond to that topic.
This week, I sent out
the hashtag MakeAMovieChristmas.
And I asked you
to take a real movie
and revise the title
to make it more Christmasy.
Within minutes, it was a
trending topic in the U.S.,
so thank you for playing along.
Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
MakeAMovieChristmas tweets
from you guys.
Here we go.
This first one's from @rawkwell.
She says...
-Oh!
-Your move, Marvel.
That's right.
This one's from
@RyanBartholomee. He says...
-Ooh!
-This one's from @JonOsborne.
He says...
-Oh!
"Hey!"
-I'd watch that.
-"Don't murder me."
-"Hermey doesn't
like you to dream."
-Oh!
-This one's from @meanseansween.
He says...
This one's from
@juliacollinsart. She says...
-I got six of them.
-[ As Batman ] I'd like to
return this air fryer, please.
I don't really get it.
It doesn't really fry anything."
[ Normal voice ] This one's from
@SheinbergLauren. She says...
-Oh!
-"A Few Good Menorahs."
-Come on. Nice.
-This one's from @briancrider.
He says...
"House of Gucci."
-"Hey, it's me, Mario!"
-This one is from
@RealTomCrawford. He says...
This one's -- itsluciano18.
He says...
-Oh! Candle.
-This one's from @ReneeJordan78.
She says...
There you go.
♪♪
-Come on.
-This one's from @Nick--
-Come on! Give it up.
"A Fish Called Kwanzaa."
-"A Fish Called Kwanzaa."
-This one's from @nickhart2000.
He says...
Last one -- This last one is
from @kyledice23.
They say...
There you go, everybody.
-Yeah!
-There you have it.
Those are our
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out more of
our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.